no
the sea is like a monster rather it is
like once
you have to be careful with its
moods but it is the sea it is very
generous and very kind it always
gives you much more than we
give it or what we  we contribute
[Music]
cisneros percebes because it is for things
with stater bros in the hardware suárez
forward
in his interest in severe women I am
knowing my name is susana I
am belen my name is darla we are percebeiros
[Music]
and
in our  family has always
worked at the barnacle our parents
tell us that their greatest dream in life
was to have a son because they wanted to
teach their son the profession
because barnacle work was a job
for men and they had one daughter and another  and
another daughter and another and we have dedicated ourselves
throughout our lives to different trades
but let's say that the sea in the end has
pulled more and since the four of us
really like the life of the sea
and in the end he is delighted with life and
e  he is the proudest and happiest man in
the world because despite not having sons he
had four daughters
stephen hart
and apart from the fact that he is considered an
exquisite I think it is closely related
to the danger of his
capture they occur in rocky places  of
cold waters and where the sea breaks with
force
that social lorenzo of
maritime guard the brotherhood of baiona
woking team
but a blow of the sea that tears you from
the stone that has the sea out or
you want a blow and without urgency 3 walton
happy to be  resort to no
joke festive tone and the soundtrack
within the dian gas sport city
bell and forms of reconstruction
entertaiment software is not a successor at
the giant level of ader that came
traditional theme life
prepare for a day of work
apparently just what it is  have breakfast
put on the neoprene suit and
approach the coast in 1520 minutes
the first thing that interests us is to
always work with a low tide
our  On the coast, our work area is
a coast and an area that is tremendously rich
in all marine resources. We are very
fortunate in that the rocks, when the
tide goes out, are exposed. They are rocks
that are full of life
[Music]
the work tool for
extraction  the third one is called raspa
respect how it is like a kind
of iron spatula and has a wooden handle
[Music]
myers this third chubby people right
now we have a quota of 3 kilos
per day per percebeiro which are the ones that
you can sell
that is, they will come out  when deciding to expose
[Music]
very gratifying to see firsthand
how our efforts have an outlet in
our own town and people
enjoy it here
tim mcgraw
[Music]
walking
reservations I have been a
chef since 1975
this is rather my specialty  of all
kinds of seafood but rather the
third
joel precedes and exercises in the sisters
can be around 60 70 useful euros or they
take very very good pe  rfect good
quality don't go out on an account cover it
with a napkin on top and those
robes on the table and when you get to the
stake tables on the napkin and
the smell comes yes it has the third
love
that's good losing with yes  they are not
excited at their point also then it is
difficult to open them to two out of ten years
the barnacles are not a
particularly pretty creature but then their flavor
makes up for it it
is a
tremendously strong flavor and with a taste of the sea and
with a spectacular texture it
is a shellfish that you will love
Almost everyone likes it very much, it is
Galician seafood
in working with if it considers
everything
that being a percebeiro is tremendously important, I believe
that our work will have continuity and
that people will come after us who
will continue to be passionate about the sea
sea is a way of life that in the end is pa
t of you [Musi
]